I've been in business for 14 years. I've
scaled six brick and mortar gyms. I did
30 plus gym turnarounds across the
country and built service companies to
over $30 million a year. Today, our
portfolio at acquisition.com is over
$250 million annually. And so, in this
video, I'm answering your questions
about how to scale your service
business. And for all these questions, I
try to make, you know, my answers as
tactical as humanly possible so that you
watching from home can immediately use
them. Enjoy. I am a chiropractor. We do
right around 2.4. Been stuck there for 5
years.
I'd like to get to 3.6 to get out The
swamp. Stuck or growing over 5 years?
We've been at 2.4 for 5 years. Yep. And
so, I don't know what's stopping us. I'd
like to get out of the swamp.
Heard.
Um and then profit margins, you're at
30%, right? Yes, sir. Yeah, okay.
I remember seeing 600,000 as a profit
number. I don't know if that's still
accurate. Okay.
Um okay, so you got 600,000 in profit
and you have Do you have You own a
partner or you're 100%? 100%. Okay.
Um
Well, what what do you want to have You
just want to Like what do you want to
have happen? Do you want to Like what do
you want to do? Do you want to go to
many locations?
Um no, I want to I I want to grow a uh
uh
main big location. And
um
you know, create a space for
family to eventually, I mean,
grow in there. If they If they don't
want to do that, then I would probably
change my goal to be an exit Okay.
What's your square footage?
Uh right now, we have 7,700. Okay, so
decently large.
>> Yeah, we occupy about 4,700 of it. Okay,
got it. And so, are you at capacity
within the space right now? No. We used
to have a supply issue till about 2
weeks ago. How great.
>> And then we hired another doctor. So,
now it's become a demand issue.
And that's where we're at now. So, how
do you get customers now?
Uh we Our highest is referral. Uh then
we get about
The next highest would be paid ads
through Facebook.
>> What percentage are ads? Uh
we do
probably about 20% from ads. About half
is from referrals, another
20% is from Google.
Okay. So, you separate Meta ads from
Google ads when you talk about ads. Yep.
Okay, got it. Um We don't actually
currently do Google ads, but that's
where they said they came from.
Heard.
Got it. Which I would probably see as
word of mouth, like I Googled you or I
Googled somebody. It's probably SEO,
something like that. But um okay. So,
2 and 1/2 million, like what stops you
from just spending more money on Meta
ads?
Uh
trust that we're doing it right. I mean,
I just want to feel like we're doing it
right.
>> than you put in?
Yeah.
Well, so you might have one of these
guys.
Which is that we need we need
attribution tracking.
So that you can know if you're putting a
dollar in and getting $5 or $10 or $20
back out. We have no clue.
But as soon as you get attribution
tracking, cuz fundamentally what what
you lack right now is an input-output
equation for the business to grow. And
so every business needs to know what are
the what are the core actions that I do
that increase how much money I make. And
if you can't define that for the
business, then for sure as [__] your
employees don't know what it is. If you
don't know what it is, right? And so for
you if you are not supply constrained
and you're demand constrained, that
means lead generation is the issue. If
lead generation is the issue, what's the
activity? The activity is going to
either be I'm going to be making
content, I'm going to be getting
affiliates that are going to be
promoting my [__] for me.
Uh I'm going to be uh running paid ads.
Right? Those are going to be kind of
like the the bigger buckets that you're
going to be going into and then you got
people who do those things on your
behalf. And so right now, do you make
content?
Yes, sir. Okay. What percentage comes
from that? Uh we just started it
uh about
2 months ago. How much do you do?
Uh we
>> going to tell you to do more. I'm just
curious.
We do four videos that gets created into
short and long per week.
Uh four videos for the month. And
>> Heard, okay.
Don't Yeah, don't
>> chopped up. Yeah, yeah. Okay, got it.
Okay, so you've got four longs and you
chop this into little shorts and things
like that. Okay, got it.
Um
All right. So,
short-term, long-term. Short-term, we're
going to get the data tracking in place.
Second step is going to be putting the
ad the the ads funnel in place and kind
of like what the sales motion is
behind that. For local, the good news is
that
uh
it's easy to do
because there's already so much trust
locally that you don't need to have
nearly the complexity of kind of like
the funnels and indoctrination and
education prior to someone making a
purchasing decision. You can pretty much
just like one call close, two two
conversation close
anybody.
Um even at very high ticket numbers,
which is one of the benefits of local.
The downside of local is that you've got
a market that's this big. Correct.
That's the downside, right? So, if you
don't want to expand markets, then you
need to dominate the market you're in.
And so, it's going to be a multi-pronged
approach. And it's kind of like I was
saying earlier, like we're going to
start with ads because that'll just get
you more in because I'm guessing right
now, if you have a good reputation, good
brand, then the ads will actually help
you more than they would help somebody
who doesn't have that footprint. But
then we're going to start probably
layering in the the content as the
second um kind of the well that needs to
continue to get dug. Again, this is
going to be long-term, and so you're
going to want to be a thought leader.
And then what happens is that if you can
if you can succeed at building the brand
long-term, and it sounds like you're a
more long-term guy, so I will I'll speak
in these terms.
Um what happens is your radius actually
continues to expand. And so, if you take
it to the natural extreme, you can go to
the Amen Clinic in New York or whatever
I think it's New York um because they
have a national reputation, but people
would fly there. And so, that's how
that's what it looks like as you
continue to expand the brand because
people just be more willing to travel to
you and pay premium prices.
Which I'm sure if we looked under the
hood, the prices probably get tweaked,
too. But like those
those are some things. And if you're in
the swamp, cash flow is actually the
biggest thing that you need. Right. Um
and so again, the pricing and packaging
is probably like again, if I was the
order of operations, pricing and
packaging would probably be number one
so we could free up cash flow. The freed
up cash flow would then funnel into the
ads so that we could get did well did
attribution then we'd put the ads in
place
start start flowing putting flow through
there and then the baseline that happens
after that is we're just going to
increase the cadence on the on the
content that demonstrates thought
leadership. Leadership. That's the path.
That makes sense. Thank you. Uh
how do you
we're we're having trouble also hiring
good high quality doctors. Mhm. In
Wyoming.
It's actually ladders up at the first
problem, cash flow. Okay. We need to fix
the pricing so that we can generate more
cash flow so that we can pay doctors so
that we can actually get the business to
not rely on you as much.
Boom. Real quick, if you were a business
owner and you were not growing as fast
as you'd like, I'd like to give you a
free gift. My team and I put together
the $100 million scaling road map, which
is basically 200 hours of us looking
over all the portfolio companies we've
had and where they got stuck and how
they got past it. And so we broke it in
these 10 stages and we made this little
kind of quiz thing where if you put in
your business information, it'll tell
you where you're at. No matter what
you're struggling with, someone else has
already struggled with it and solved it.
And so I'd like to give you this thing
absolutely free. You can go to
acquisition.com/roadmap,
plug in your business information, and
if you want us to actually help you
deconstruct the business and you're
trying to scale, we'd love to help you
out. On the thank you page, you can just
book a call with my team and we will
look at the business, see if we can
help, and if we can, we'll fly you out
to Vegas and we'll do this in person
live.
>> I sell basically complete digital
marketing services to service based
businesses in Australia. I move SMBs? Uh
like cleaning companies, stuff like
that. Cleaning, yard work, and Average
revenue for them?
>> revenue per company is anywhere between
half a million to 2.5. Tough. Uh they're
the ones I sell.
Uh I moved pivoted the company's gone
from zero to 500k in the last four four
months. It's I pivoted from fitness. Uh
just happened so it worked out well. Uh
so they've all been wound down getting
other people operate. I'd like to
ideally get to
eight figures.
Uh in terms of what's stopping me, I
well, I spent the whole 28 hours here
going through every framework I could to
figure out what's wrong. Yeah. I just
want to figure out
>> Can I tell you what it is?
Good. I also want to figure out where
would be, besides like getting
operations moving out to other people
and making sure I'm not involved in
delivery, where would be the best use of
my time.
>> channel suck.
Yep. Yeah. That's what's going to Yeah.
So, you're four four months in, so
you're it's it's brand new.
>> It's very new. And you haven't seen all
the [__] that's about to happen. So,
what's going to happen is because you're
because you're servicing SMBs, Yep.
their volatility will translate over to
your volatility. Mhm.
And independent of how well you do, they
will start churning.
Um and you have probably mastered the
sales function, which is why you're
growing quickly.
>> Yep. Um but you also will have like CAC
will never be cheaper than it is today.
Yeah. CAC will never
>> So, CAC will always go up. Mhm. And
churn is going to start eating into the
business because SMBs suck.
And so, we what's going to happen is
that your margins will continue to
compress and compress and compress and
you have to spend more and more. CAC
will go up. You'll have to hire more
people because of churn, that's what
you're going to think you're going to
have to do in order to fix the churn,
but it's not. Whatever, let's go to it.
And so, you're going to keep going, keep
going, keep going. And so, revenue keep
going up, but the margin gets smaller
and smaller until eventually you're just
like, I feel like I'm running a
nonprofit and I have to just keep
selling stuff and I don't even feel
confident about it cuz I got all these
people complaining, but it's really cuz
they're the business owners who suck.
And then you think, maybe I should take
over more responsibility for the
business owners. I'm going to start
maybe doing some sort of sales motion,
some sort of you know, nurture motion
because they suck at sales, they don't
know how to run their business and
that's why they can't market with me,
but I'm going to do this cuz I want to
take a you know, responsibility this and
all of that is just wrong. Yeah.
And so, if you want to get to three
million bucks a year, you can just do
what you're currently doing. Yeah.
You'll just sell more and
LTV will probably be What's your price
point? Uh $450 a week. A week. Okay, so
you're 2K a month ish. Yeah. So, you're
right in the sweet spot of churn. Like
that is like if you like
1,500 to 3K a month for an SMB,
average stick is going to be 4 to 6
months. Mhm.
Um and so you can back now back of
napkin how many you selling a month
right now? Uh I'm selling about 10 a
month at the moment. Cool.
So,
if you're selling 10 per month, right?
And uh you said 2K was your price point,
right? So, let's say that we have five
turns on that on average.
10K? Yep. Right? And 10 per month?
Yep.
So, you're going to get to 100K-ish per
month.
Um and then you will stall.
And so, at that point you'll either have
to increase unit sold or increase LTV
and then you'll keep thinking, "Man, if
I could just get this to go up, it would
be amazing." But you won't be able to.
Yeah, cuz it's just a nice number.
>> Um and so, the only way to really make
SMB work is to go the opposite end is to
go super super cheap. Yeah. And then
build something that cost you nothing.
So, there's
nothing to deliver. Yeah. So, it's like
$400 a month or less
for an SMB if it's a nuisance style.
So, I'll give you some examples. Um if
you were like, "I can get you ranked on
first three of maps
in your local area and I charge
$400, $500 a month."
They'll do it cuz they can see it. Yep.
And they'll pay for that. Um review
management
um and SEO stuff.
Uh they will pay $300, $400 a month and
they will stick on that. You'll get like
30 to 40 month stick rates on that. Um
but you'll close way more sales
velocity. Uh so, LTV's actually similar
to this but CAC stays super low Yep. um
as a result.
But I know you just got a fitness which
you probably got out cuz it was terrible
and hard. Um
you might need to just go and get to
there and then you'll feel good about
things. Um like you might need to walk
this path rather than believe me. But
that's probably what that's what's going
to happen. So,
what do you want to have happen?
Not walk to not have to walk the path in
the first place.
Um Get less amount of time.
>> So, this is like the
just me just being real like
marketing there's so I mean obviously a
lot of marketers follow my stuff and so
I get a disproportionate amount of
marketing agencies and I've seen every
model under the sun. Um
SMBs suck as customers. Um, and so you
have you have to do this one or the
other. You have to go up market if you
go down market. Um, and you guys are
really cheap and it's something that's
super automated uh or you do truly do
more of these high touch services but
you do with a business that actually
knows their metrics, actually has a
sales process, already has a proven
model uh rather than all of them just
like wanting to change their stuff all
the time, not knowing what they're doing
to begin with cuz like they're expecting
you to figure out something that they
haven't figured out themselves. Um, and
so that's so like your price either goes
up and you serve a higher level avatar
uh or it goes down and you serve the one
you are now but you make sure that your
delivery is almost nothing. Yeah. And
then it becomes a CAC issue because you
have to offset CAC and so then it
becomes big head long tail, one time set
up into very small recurring monthly
high gross margin.
Understood.
>> Those are the two models that work for
what you want to So drop low, go high.
And then the middle's just a dead zone.
>> Where everyone dies.
Cool.
Makes sense. Thank you. We do uh we're a
WAS so website as a service um based
company. So we build websites, do
digital marketing services, that kind of
stuff. We cater to small medium
businesses, small businesses.
Uh average revenue per customer is 450
bucks a month. Okay. Subscription based
company. Yeah. And we're at yeah, we're
at 20 million uh bucks in revenue and
we're at 20 million
>> Notice. Example, right price.
Really small, you price it super low and
it works. All right, go ahead. And we
want to get to 80 80 million bucks in
revenue in about 3 years. Okay.
So uh the question we're asking
ourselves is we're in an industry where
AI is very disruptive.
Um every day that goes by, you know,
it's constantly degrading and decaying
our product. Uh
and at the same time we have kind of
this one channel risk that we're living
with. All of our sales, 100% of our
growth has been done through outbound
cold calling. Love it. Yeah, it's great.
Um,
but again, cold calling is becoming
harder and harder in the industry is
decaying. So, we're we're constantly
we're trying to figure out
>> is decaying? Yeah. What do you mean by
that? Churn is going up? Churn is
slightly ticking up, but
um,
at the end of the day, you know, AI is
making it easier and easier for our
customers to be able to build their own
websites.
>> Yeah.
Well, yeah, I know.
With the type of customer we deal with,
they're not usually super sophisticated,
so it we do have time.
>> out about ChatGPT, so
Yeah, exactly. So, we we have time, but
>> Some of you guys still fax, so I think
you got time. Yeah, but this is the
question, right? So, do we double down
on on on marketing and create like a an
inbound channel and really invest hard
into that, or do we do um, do we try to
innovate on the product and figure out
what else they need and like build a
revenue engine? Uh, right now we're kind
of we're doing we're trying to do both,
but it's obviously limiting. So, this is
this is really really good. I love that
you asked this. So, um, I went on this
long rant the other day about this
particular topic, which is solving
problems that don't exist. Okay.
So, unless cuz like you have a
narrative, you have a story around
AI is decaying the business, but all I
hear is that you have customers and your
job just got way easier.
Explain.
So, you know what I mean? Like, if you
were like, "Our churn is escalating by
10% per month." I'd be like, "We have a
problem. We need to change something."
But, if it's not really showing up in
any meaningful way in terms of the
business itself,
I think there's plenty of people who
will just be super laggards on this and
are not going to be Replit, Vibe Coding.
They never bought your [__] to begin
with. Yeah. Like, the person who is
super into AI right now
wasn't hiring WaaS anyways. They built
their own website Mhm. before AI made it
code easy. Haha.
Like, it cuz I mean to be fair, website
building software not that complicated.
Um so, you said there was two paths. So,
one is you know, change the product
around. My opinion, I wouldn't that's
probably wouldn't be where I'm focused
unless I had some
business metric that was way off that
that I'm not seeing.
Um I would be doubling down on the
acquisition side. What's your LT What's
your number of months average stick?
Uh so, it's a 29 months. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That's the game. It's It's usually
a Yeah, it's 30 to 40. It's It's the the
highest I've seen
uh
was 38 for this type of business. So,
like you're right. You're right in the
in the sweet spot there. You're a little
higher priced. I think they were $2.99.
Like Yeah. it all works out in the same,
you know, same same.
So,
yeah, I think you just double down on
inbound. So, paid ads.
Paid ads, yeah. Yeah, and I would just
see if you could get them to prepay for
the quarter so you can offset CAC.
Mhm.
Okay.
Um on that subject, if you don't mind,
in terms of prepaying for the quarter,
you know, again, our customers are
pretty price sensitive. There's people
that are cheaper than us, obviously, as
you've seen before.
Um my fear is the amount of churn that
will generate some, you know, we build
90% of our customers on credit cards and
we hold on to 10% that pay us through
like pad and through checks and that
kind of [__] It's all It's awful, but
you know, we're going to experience
churn if we're like, "Hey, you need to
you know, prepay us up up front." You'd
still
>> We wouldn't churn, just close fewer,
right?
Um close fewer? Absolutely, and I think
customers that are with us would leave
us.
Why would the people who are with you
leave you for how you treat your new
customers?
Sorry?
People that are with us would leave us.
>> you change your billing process for
existing customers. Got you. I'm saying
if you're doubling down on inbound, what
will go up is CAC because you'll have
media spend in addition to the sales
commission. And so, to offset that from
a cash flow How cash flow positive are
you right now? Uh so, we did 3.6 in
EBITDA last year. Generated about
>> Interesting. Yeah. Yeah.
That's lowish. It's lowish. Yeah. Yeah,
I'm curious about that.
>> Hm? We're heavy on people.
Dude, AI. I know.
I know.
Big thing. I know. It's like you're
worried about them doing it, you're not
even doing it.
>> Correct. Right?
Yeah. Right?
Right? Yeah. So, like um okay, so this
is what I would actually do. I would
probably spend the next 6 months
reorganizing the workflow, probably
reduce head count by 50% using AI
workflows in order to actually do the
same thing, increase the margin from 3.6
to like 7 um or more. With the ash added
cash flow, you wouldn't have to change
the price on the front end. You'd be
willing to go negative for a quarter in
the acquisition knowing you're going to
get 29 on the back.
Hm.
That's how I'd actually fix it.
Okay.
Makes sense.
Chill, right? Cool. Yeah. Nice, man. I
sell CFO advisory. We will do probably
about 2.9 this year.
>> Amazing. I would love to be at like 20
million. Okay. Um but what's stopping
me?
I have
we've made all this stuff.
I have two books. I've fired my CPA. I
have Tax-Free Millionaire. I've made all
these courses. I don't know what to do
with them. I don't know how to market. I
don't know how to advertise. I've never
done any of this. You're doing 3 million
a year.
All organic. Yeah, I mean, you're
obviously not marketing shitty. Um so,
you've got all this stuff, right? You
got these books, you got these courses.
You make content?
Yes. Okay, so you are marketing. Well,
I've never put them out there. Like I
don't know what to do with it.
Wait, huh? Okay, hold on. So, you've got
all this stuff in your back pocket. So,
you've got Tax-Free Millionaire book
and/or course. You've got Fire Your CPA
book and/or course.
And you make content about tax
accounting [__] Yeah. And so, people
come in and buy your tax planning [__]
Right? And you're trying to get to 20.
Yeah. Do people churn out?
Well, I've never tried to sell anybody
on the stuff that I've made. Well, but
we don't need but like forget let's
erase those for a moment.
Those are not real things for the
purpose of our conversation.
If you didn't have those things, what
would you do to grow the business?
People call our office and they come in
and I sell them for monthly service. And
I get referrals for tax planning.
In person or virtual. Yeah. Okay, but
you're local?
I'm local. We have a bricks and mortar.
I have a billboard. But most I do, yeah.
But most of our clients are are are not
in Texas. Okay, heard. Okay, so they're
coming from the content. They call up.
You guys sell them whatever. Referrals,
yeah. Absolutely.
And what are you growing at annually?
What am I what?
>> Growing at annually.
Uh last year I was 2.2. Okay, that's
great. Yeah, super good. So whatever, 30
35% annual growth, that's awesome. Okay,
so what's the um
So you you want to get to 20 and I'm
guessing you just don't want to wait
like 7 years to get to 20 at that
compound rate. Yeah. Right? So as long
as you're keeping customers, when I said
do they churn, that's what I meant. Like
are they stay Do people stay with you?
Uh the people that are on monthly stay a
lot more than the people that come in
just for a one-time tax plan.
>> What's the um
This will be fun for you. Okay. So
what's the I'll give you like some some
business accounting.
Um what's sales velocity right now?
I don't know what what
>> How many units a month do you sell?
Uh on the monthly reoccurring? Yeah.
There's probably about 190 clients.
>> No, how many do you sell every month?
Oh, new ones?
We're we've closed down for new sales
cuz
I'm trying to figure everything out. So
nothing right now. Nothing. Well, that
will not grow the business. That for
sure. That
There's my
Yeah, I'll be here all day, guys.
Okay, so
So you have a goose egg there. Okay.
But, okay, you have this other stuff.
Why do we care?
Well, that's what I want to do. Like, I
like the products. I like to educate. I
like to be in front of the camera. Like,
I want to do all that. Okay.
Well, what's wrong with the business
that you decided to stop selling stuff
for? It's [__] hard. That's why.
>> get you. It's No, like, to fulfill on it
and
>> Sh- You could always just start a
business where you sell everybody else's
stuff.
Um well, I missed my joke. You missed
it. Okay. And what I'm trying to get to
now, like, AI, what you were saying is
going to completely obliterate our
industry, which I'm really excited
about, because I want to dive into it. I
want to leverage AI tools and even
overseas partners doing low-level stuff,
because people in our industry are
really slow and outdated and they
Yeah. But, all of these are not things
that you would solve with marketing.
You're supply constrained and so you're
like, "How do I market more?" I'm like,
"You can't even take people."
Well, I want to market like for courses
and to buy my books and things like
that.
>> a valuable business right now.
No, I I I do. Yeah.
>> I know. Why are we Why would we start
another business that's not selling
people?
>> me, but I I want to do that, too.
Yeah, I mean, like, like, I make the
content I continue to repeat and I get I
get my my memes made of me of like,
"Alex is going to say it's shit's hard
and hard things are hard and hard hard
hard." And it's because it just never
stops being hard.
It just always sucks.
Like, the course thing will suck, too.
You just don't know it yet.
Ask the course people. They'll tell you
it sucks.
>> That's great advice. Right? They're
like, "It sucks." Yeah.
Customers aren't sticky. They'll expect
you to do everything. They're like, "I'm
not a tax-free millionaire already and I
bought your $17 course." Like, [__] you,
you know, like
Like, that's, you know, that's what's
going to happen.
But, you have you have a service that
people aren't turning out of. I'm
guessing
>> Yeah. I mean some, but they're pretty
sticky. Yeah. No No one who No one who
has bad churn stops selling. I'll say
that.
So like the fact that you're comfortable
enough that you're like, "Oh, we don't
need to take customers for a while."
Like I'm sure your stuff is
better than you think. Um but I think
that we have to think Basically,
you're supply constrained.
And so we just need to fix the supply
constraint of your business. Because if
I said, "Hey, we found a way What are
your margins right now?"
About 20 25%.
>> Okay. So if we said, "Okay, let's see if
we can find
um offshore talent that can give your
existing team two or three x leverage.
So you don't have to increase internal
head count, you can increase external
head count. And then when AI comes in,
you can basically wipe those guys off
the map and then fine, right? So it's
like, yeah, they don't have jobs or
families. Uh
They're overseas. They're not real. Um
I'm kidding. So I know half you guys are
overseas, so that was a joke. Um
But yeah. So I think that we need to
create operating leverage. We have to
look at basically how the services are
being delivered so that we can figure
out how to get each person two or three
more, you know, x in terms of their
ability to deal with customers.
Um probably there's a little bit of tech
that's missing because this is for
everybody. Everybody Every entrepreneur
I talk to is like, "I want to be AI
first, right? And then you're like using
Jeff GP for emails." Like that's not how
you're AI first.
Um the first thing that you have to do
in order to have an AI first company is
you have to be a data first company.
Because AI works with data. If you don't
have data, then there's no [__] AI.
So you have to have complete data first
from your approach and have an
architecture in place so that you know
all the elements of the business from
data and then we can put the AI layer on
top to put reinforcement training in
place in order to actually train it to
do stuff. So if that's where you want to
go, which does have tremendous operating
leverage, and like just for everybody,
this is the once-in-a-generation move
right now. So, 25 years ago cloud
computing came out and then, you know,
software went from CDs to cloud and that
and then all of the software companies
and all that boom was the last 25 years
and all the billionaires were made. The
next boom is this, right? And so, we're
early and so the hard of this is like,
"Well, the pieces don't all fit together
perfectly yet." And it's like, "Well,
that's the figure out that we make lots
of money from, right?" Okay. So, I don't
think the solution is you selling a
course cuz you just happened to have
recorded it. I think that we need to fix
the supply constraint first and then
you'll use all those things as marketing
assets to increase demand when the time
comes.
So, save those in your back pocket.
There's nothing wrong with them. But, I
want to look at the model, increase
operating leverage that'll probably also
increase margin, start making this
number more than zero. Okay. Which I
promise, you can take this to the bank,
if you do make that not zero, you will
grow faster.
Um
you'll make more money if you sell
people.
Uh and then I think from there, so it's
like
increase operating leverage through
offshoring, add in data layer. Once the
data layer is there, then we can add in
the AI component that further increases
operating leverage. Once you put the
remote team in, you'll then be able to
sell again. If you get to the point
where you're like, "I've now reached my
new two or three X capacity without even
marketing." Then great. If you do need
to market more, then use the assets that
are in your back pocket to go do more
lead gen.
It was like four or five steps, but
that's how I think they're at. Thank
you. I sell roofing and exterior
remodeling. Sweet. Uh we do uh close to
6 million this year.
>> Amazing. Um I would like to be at 100
million. Okay. So, what's stopping me
and I'll I'll be a little bit
vulnerable.
I would say it's comfort, distractions,
and fear.
And food? Fear. Oh, sorry. I was like
All right, good to know. You know.
>> food. No.
Sometimes I feel that way, too.
Uh So, the the comfort is I have built
the business. I've replaced myself in
every aspect. I can work two to three
hours a week and it run fine. Okay. Um
fear, I would say the fear of losing
family time. Mhm. Uh the work-life
balance.
>> Sure. And the distractions are
uh my other I've got another business,
junk removal business. Um
I've got real estate. I've got
uh
just all kinds of little businesses.
>> you think you should do that you're not
doing that you want me to tell you to
do?
So So I know I need to go all in again.
And And I did that the first five years
that I that
>> worked out? And it worked out great.
>> Uh-huh. Um went through COVID. Um I got,
you know, kept the business going really
well. Mhm. And I worked myself out of a
job.
Got comfortable. Okay.
So
I don't know what I'm looking for you to
tell me to do. Well, I'll say I'll say
this differently. Um
I think regrets come when we imagine
the upside that we don't have without
taking into account the cost that we
didn't suffer.
And so
Sure.
Uh
I think I think we regret um when we
imagine the upside that we didn't get
without also considering the downside
that we didn't suffer
to get it.
Um and so I think that's where a lot of
regret comes from cuz it's not it's not
real. So it's like maybe there's some
girl that got away or some business
opportunity that got away and we just
imagine
this amazing thing but not the trade-off
that we would have to do in order to get
it. We just imagine the upside without
the downside. And so I would say a
couple things. So one is um
I think that there are there are
trade-offs
that we always have to make. And I don't
I don't think they're right or wrong. I
think they're just they're preference.
There's no right answer to how much
work-life balance you want to have. It's
right for you.
And so
said differently, if I like cookies
and I'm good with that, and I also want
a six-pack, I just prefer cookies to a
six-pack.
It's just that's the trade, and I think
the dissatisfaction comes from wanting
both. Right. Right. And so either
want less
or trade more.
Okay. And I think that's really what it
comes down to in terms of like is there
a path where I can work no more than I
currently am um to go from 60 to 100?
There probably is. It depends on how
much you're willing to pay other people.
And so you might have to take a
short-term hit in terms of profitability
uh to bring in the level of talent that
you want to expand the business on your
behalf to where you want it to go.
And so as long as you were the type of
person character-wise that they would
want to follow and believe in your
vision, and you can make your vision big
enough that they think that their
aspirations can fit within it, you can
get that type of person.
But like it's it's 100% like you're
you're graduating right now into the who
game. Yeah. Um but there's levels of
whos. You know, like I remember um the
first time I hired a $50,000 a year
employee, and I was like this is the
[__] This is what I'm talking about.
You know what I mean? Like I went from
minimum wage, you know, labor to 50, I
was like this they're they can read,
they can write. Like let's let's go. You
know what I mean? Uh and then I I hired
my first six-figure employee, and I was
like oh what was I talking about? Like
this is what's going on. And then I have
my first 250, first 500, first million,
first multi-million dollar per year
employee. Um
it's just levels. And so um Sheron,
who's our president, said this to me
years ago, but I always remember he said
the best the best talent's always in the
future.
So whatever we have today, the best
people are always ahead of you, not
behind you.
And so um I think for you, if we if you
really do want to accomplish it without
making the trade, you will make a trade
cuz if you change nothing, nothing will
change, right? So we have to change some
some component of your life. And so the
question is which thing do you value the
least?
Do you value having more profit or more
time with your family in the short term?
In the long term, you can make it up.
You won't make up family time in the
long term. You can make the profit up in
the long term. Right. So, if you're
willing to give up short-term profit,
you can bring in high-level talent, and
then they can lead the growth.
Okay. In terms of the uh the fear stuff,
I mean, I would just say like just hold
hold the line.
If you don't you're like, "I'm afraid of
losing time with the family." It's like
just don't.
Like I you know. And then in terms of
the real estate thing, I see real estate
cuz I know about entrepreneurs. I have a
ton of real estate. Um
I don't like as long as you're not like
actively running it.
Um
Like that's what I'm a big fan of like
REITs and funds. Yeah. Uh because you
have if you have, you know, good
partners in that stuff. Um
they can just run it. You can make
better than the market and then
but it's not it doesn't change anything
about what I do. Like me putting in the
S&P or me buying another big building
changes nothing about my life. And so,
it's not a distraction unless you're
like, "You know, if we could add a
gazebo. And what if we added a different
roof cuz I'm a roofer. And what if I
combined what I'm really You're like,
"Dude, stop. Just like let the real
estate be the real estate. Let the
business be the business and just keep
them apart." As long as you're good
there cuz I think it's a distraction.
Um
Actually, let me double-checking that
real quick, which is when you said your
the distraction thing that you're afraid
of, why are you afraid of that?
I'm not afraid of it.
>> Okay.
>> I'm just I've got ADHD and I I
I collect gold and silver. I buy houses.
I buy buildings. I
mean, it's just
Yeah. a little bit of the red dress.
Well, as long as it doesn't change
anything about what you do, I don't
care. But if it's like, "Now, I check
this stuff all the time and it like eats
up my days." Then yeah, I would say
that's a problem.
Um
And it's only a problem if you decide
it's a problem. Like you might just like
that stuff. It's just like I sacrifice
my goals cuz I enjoy this ADD.
You know what I mean? Like the cost of
the big thing is the new stuff that you
have to give up to keep it going.
Yeah. Thank you. I feel like there's
some amens. This is great.
It's like
a good meal, right? Yeah.
I appreciate it.
Um but yeah, that's the like the cost of
the big thing is all the new stuff you
have to give up that you don't get to
pursue. All the exciting things that you
will no longer participate in because
you want to do one thing big.
Okay. And I think um for me personally,
I had this moment um I think a while
ago, but like I had this realization of
how long it takes to get good at
anything.
And then I thought about oh, I only have
like 30 or 40 more productive years
at most. And so I'm like, I've got like
four or five big seasons in me left.
Yeah. And so
that's it. And so I don't have like
unlimited shots on goal. I've got four
or five big runs in me.
And so I think like realizing that it's
kind of like Warren Buffett talks about
if every person just had a punch card
with 20 punches on it and that's the
only thing you could invest in, you
could never sell it, you'd make way
better investments. I see entrepreneurs
the same way in terms of what business
opportunities we'll pursue. Because if
we take the hypothetical extreme that if
we want to build something really big,
it's going to take a long time.
Then it means we can't do that many
things.
So. Hopefully that helps. I appreciate
that answer cuz I thought you were going
to say sell everything and
I mean, they're investments. I mean, I'm
not going to tell you sell your
investments. I would say
keep passive stuff passive. Don't make
it active. That's like incurring cost.
Cuz if you're going to make it active,
then make active money.
Yeah. If you're like, I want I want to
take my passive money and then it make
it cost me more time to get 5% better
returns, it's like you're going to get
way better returns in your active income
than your passive.
And just I would just keep active
active, keep passive passive.
Thank you. Appreciate you. Real quick,
I'm going to show you the exact 10-stage
roadmap from zero to 100 million plus
that less than 1% of companies finish
I've now done multiple times. And so I
can say with a lot of confidence that
these are the stages as head count
increases that you need to get through.
And I broke each of these down by eight
different functions of the business,
what the constraint feels like, like
what are the symptoms of it when you're
going through it, and then what steps we
actually took to graduate. And we've
done this across software, physical
products,
service businesses, brick and mortar,
all of this, and it works. And it's my
gift to you, it's absolutely free. And
so the link's in the description, but
you just go acquisition.com/roadmap,
just enter your info, and it'll spit it
right back to you, all free. My family
owns a residential fence company, so we
sell fences to homeowners.
Uh our current revenue is roughly about
20 million.
Um I think a good goal for us would be
50.
Um I think what is stopping us is
leadership and A-players within our
sales and management, and also
standardization of our processes and SOP
creation. Okay.
I believe you.
Okay.
So, right now, do you need more
customers? Not necessarily. Well, do you
need more We have to figure out right
off the bat. Do you need more customers,
or can you not can not handle the the
the stuff you got? We can handle the
stuff we have. You can. So, you need
more customers.
We need more lead people, people to
answer the leads, and people to close
the deals. Okay, so you have leads. You
have a sales constraint. Yes. Got it.
Okay. So, how many sales people do you
need? It sounds like a similar How many
sales people do you need in order to
deal with the
leads issue?
We currently have five. I would say we
at least need to double that.
Okay. So, what's stopping you from
doubling it?
Um
I think it's part
the nerves that the market might not
last and need or require that many
people.
So, kind of putting all the stuff
>> be a demand issue again?
Yeah, well, I mean, it's not like we
don't have a current demand issue. We
have a plenty of leads coming in. We've
got a whole separate staff that are
>> the fear from? What are your margins?
See, this This where it's hard for me
because I'm not the CE- CEO. I'm the
right-hand woman to kind of the founder,
so I don't know specifically. You don't
know the margins?
As the right hand?
No, cuz I feel like it's also kind of a
data problem that we have of not being
able to collect the proper data and know
that it's actually correct or accurate
as well.
Well, I'll say it's one of two So you
said we're afraid to hire these people.
I would say why if it's like it's just
between my ears and I have have
irrational fears for things I'd be like,
all right, let's get over it. If it's
because we have no cash flow, then it's
like okay, we have cash flow issues and
we have to go down that kind of decision
tree.
Um
assuming you don't I mean, have you ever
heard of the CEO saying that they have
cash flow issues? Not necessarily.
>> Okay, well then I would be like, why
don't we hire five more sales guys?
We're in the process of doing that.
Okay, there we go. Okay, great. Got it.
No, you're good. Yeah.
26% is our kind of Okay, great. You
know, we're there.
You know,
we
fine-tune the back end. Mhm. Now it's
upgrading sales app. Okay.
We have plenty of leads coming in. Yep.
Stop.
The our process of how we used to do it
is now changed. Okay. And
like you said, it's doubling up. We're
in a market where it's
it slows down a little bit cuz it's
winter fencing Minnesota. Cool.
>> Mhm.
But we still go through all winter.
Cold?
You know, the culture with her help
Yeah. so everybody knows.
Um
and uh yeah, we're on that doorway to
finding the right
you know.
Is it all a
>> Not knowing the Yeah. Not knowing the
right path of how to bring in the right
sales manager.
>> Yeah.
Basically, you need to build a
recruiting machine for sales cuz you're
getting to the point you have five sales
guys now? Yeah. Yeah.
Um and are you doing any Do you do any
self-gen or is it all
All paid. It's all paid. Okay, yeah. So
um
the people who who do who do home
services at a certain scale, which is
right where you're at right now, you
start needing to develop basically like
a sales academy
um that's internal. And so
just like
you have
you've religion
you got nurture
you've got sales
you've got, you know, uh onboarding of
some sort and then you've got, you know,
retention and ascension for a customer,
right?
You're going to have app gen
app nurture
interviewing
works the same way.
Onboarding
and then retention and ascension of the
sales people.
It's just that we have to build a
parallel structure within the business
always
so that we can, just like we spend money
reliably in our demand gen side, we need
to be able to spend money reliably on
the supply gen side.
And so those just have to be parallel
functions that exist within the
business. And so just like you probably
know I'll bet you know like what your
CTRs are, what your opt-in rates are,
what your, you know, what percentage of
leads you close, what percentage show,
all that kind of stuff, right? On this
side.
Yeah.
What's good?
Well, just like you know those stats
here, you just need to know those stats
here.
Are you guys doing L2 with us?
Oh, good. Yeah, I was like cuz we build
these things out of like all the time.
Yeah, but that's what you need to do. We
just have to build out the basically the
entire sales the the the pipeline, the
funnel flow
of of
And so I was I'll complete the thought
in a second. Um
So when I was talking to you yesterday,
2 seconds ago, about this
how much does a sales guy make you?
Right now.
Gross profit.
200K just for simple math. And that's in
gross profit?
Yeah.
Okay, and then how much
>> you put down there? I'm sorry.
I said So, what did you say? How much
How much gross profit do they make?
>> different cuz we have five in-house,
five out-house. Let's think of
It's really like a 10 You have your
manager outside, you have your inside
sales. That's kind of our pie. Yeah,
okay.
Um
20 million so a year Each guy's good
We divide by 10, 2 million bucks. Just
be Keep We'll keep it simple. And then
what do you pay them? Upwards max about
200. Okay, 200 for the best guys. Okay,
fine. And then gross profit on this? Uh
probably
right now 50?
Out of 2 million? Like what's your gross
profit? Not net, gross profit. What's
cost of goods? Uh
about half that. Okay, yeah. So, 1
million. So, for me I see this and I see
a five to one which by the way like some
of the best returns you get in the
business are just your cost to acquire
talent versus lifetime gross profit per
employee.
And so, if I know that we can generate 1
million dollars in gross profit, I said,
"Hey, you could put 200 grand in the S&P
or we can put 200 grand into this
machine."
It's all in.
Yeah. You get a You get a million in
gross profit and then you have your
enterprise value probably also 8x uh for
your business. It's like great, 8
million tax-free for 200k. Sounds like a
deal.
And there was a little add-on, you know,
to be honest at the beginning of your
when you came out and
Sorry for your loss, but Oh, you're
good.
>> same kind of tension that
the daughter and I Yeah.
You know, so
trying to fix that here and there.
Are you guys related? He's my dad. Oh,
there we go. That makes it easier. Okay.
Uh
I know, you're good. Um I mean, I I have
I have no words of advice there.
Um but this is what we need to do to the
business.
Yeah, I limit my scope.
No, I just meant with the the scale.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> That's what I meant. It was kind of a
home run hit for Oh, good. Okay, cool.
in a different way. No, I appreciate
that. Well, yeah, I mean the whole point
wasn't like hopefully everybody here
didn't have somebody die yesterday, you
know what I mean? But
um but we all have [__] that happens,
right? And so like um like if I look at
this thing for me, and the reason this
is kind of important cuz I I was I was
going to go in one of two directions. I
was going to either do that or just I
was going to let the spirit move me. Um
but
what is limiting most of y'all's
businesses, which is the stuff that no
one actually wants to talk about, is the
fact that like you aren't good enough as
entrepreneurs.
So, you haven't achieved enough yet. You
haven't sustained the success you have
long enough, and people don't want to
work for you cuz they don't believe in
the vision you have.
That's the real thing. Because business
at the highest level can really be
boiled down to find world-class people
and get out of their way. You've heard
Branson talk about it. You've heard
Steve Jobs talk about it, and it's true.
The problem is they don't want to work
for you.
Real.
Because Steve Jobs is like, "We're going
to add another hundred billion to
Apple." And people are like, "Wow, that
sounds amazing." And when you meet
world-class talent like that, those guys
are making $20 million bonuses per year,
right? Different levels to the game. And
so, I bring this stuff to say that if
you were a small business, which is the
vast majority of people here, um then
you have to win on character.
They have to want to work for you.
And I think learning how to master these
elements of like not being a hothead,
not being somebody who, you know, turns
on a dime. Um if you have a bad day, no
one knows about it. I think those are
the things that allow you to get way
basically punch above your weight class
because you basically always have to
punch above to get that talent, and then
that talent pulls the business up.
And so, I'll tell you the story, and
then I'll I'll switch to the next
person, which is
I um when we sold Gym Launch, some of
you guys may have heard this, but when
we sold Gym Launch, there was this long
table, um like the board room in there,
and we had uh my team on this side, and
we had the private equity team on this
side. And they'd raised $1.2 billion
um in funds to do their stuff, and I was
doing my back and napkin. I was like,
"This guy is going to make $400 million
in the next 5 years." I was like, that's
chill, taking no risk.
Um
and I did the math on what he was going
to make on Gym Launch and I was like,
he's going to make more money on my
company than I did.
And what was interesting to me though is
that I saw his entire team and I saw my
team and every single person on his team
was better than every single person on
my team and it was this very visual
stark contrast between his team and my
team and I was like,
got it.
And so I just vowed that whatever the
next business I was going to do, I
needed to have a vision that was
significantly bigger so I could attract
a different level of talent so they
could make something bigger happen.
So, that's a a slightly softer answer
but um you need to build the talent
funnel,
put that in place and then
not be mean.
Thank you. Yeah.